a baby's cry has been voted one of the
worst sounds on earth making it stop is
the holy grail of parenting here we have
a a crying baby enter dr. Robert
Hamilton 23 million people have seen him
perform a miracle I fold his right arm
like this and then his left arm in front
and then very gently hold his little
bottom and gently rock him up and down
just like that is this magic that baby
just stopped crying who is this doctor
or should I say magician we're in Santa
Monica to ask the magician pediatrician
how he became the baby whisperer when I
examine the child in the hospital or
here in my office I frequently make them
cry over the years I've been able to
really perfect this method of holding
them and it works well we've brought
them up and down very gently sometimes
we stir him to the left and we serve him
to the right but how does this magic
work dr. Hamilton believes that this
technique works because it mimics the
babies experience in the womb by folding
the baby's arms across its chest it
creates a sense of containment so that's
a sense of familiarity for them the
gentle rocking motion mimics the
sensation of floating inside the
amniotic sac so what I do is I take one
hand like that other hand like that and
very gently hold the 45-degree angle has
nothing to do with comforting the baby
and everything to do with interesting
the baby it's almost as though the
baby's going oh
hello world this is new I like it
suddenly they're at this angle that
they're not used to experiencing usually
they're on their backs you see the
ceiling they see some faces coming over
this combination of the familiar and the
new provides a lot of different stimuli
that overwhelm the babies instinct to
cry I've had four babies and I wish I
had known about the hold oh the times
hopefully this is helpful to you thank
you for your attention my best
to your family
you